[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Gabrielle Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir mathil alors on continue
de parler du ralbol des agriculteurs
hier certains ont pu rencontrer une
ministre dans les ivelines oui il s'agit
d'Aurore berger la ministre délégué
chargé de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et de la lutte contre les
discriminations était hier soir à joir
Pontchartrain elle présentait ses vœux
aux habitants de la 10e circonscription
des Yvelines dont elle était la député
il y a encore quelques mois desvux au
côté du député actuel Philippe Emmanuel
et quelques agriculteurs ont donc
profité de l'opportunité pour faire
remonter à la ministre leur inquiétude
plutôt dans la soirée ils avaient pu
également échanger avec la sous-préfète
de Rambouillet Florence Gilbert on
écoute les propos recueillis par Nicolas
dandr on s'est un petit peu invité à ses
vœux en toute courtoisie pour exprimer
le le ralbol général qui monte depuis
des années puis là qui qui émerge au
niveau nationale là en ce mois de
janvier sera le bol il a un peu trois
trois thématiques le problème de dignité
du du manque de reconnaissance qu'on a
vis-à-vis de des consommateurs ou des
politiques un problème de revenu et un
problème de de surnorme de
surtransposition des des RG la
réglementation européenne au niveau
français je suis à leur disposition pour
les rencontrer comme j'ai toujours été
depuis 7 ans je pense qu'il faut pas se
tromper de combat on a un combat à mener
ensemble avec les agriculteurs parce que
encore une on a l'alimentation la plus
durable et la plus saine au monde et
c'est d'abord ça qu'il faut rappeler
donc qui est de l'exigence évidemment je
comprend on a envie d'être de plus en
plus exigeant mais on est déjà encore
une fois ceux qui somes le plus donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi aussi rappeler ça
direction versaill à présent où une fête
juive étaé célébrée aujourd'hui oui vous
l'avez dit Mathilde la fête de
toubichevat il s'agit du nouvel an des
arbres qui a lieu cette année le 25
janvier pour l'occasion un olivier a été
planté dans les jardins du domaine de
Madame Élisabeth à Versailles c'était
une première la plantation s'est faite
en présence de représentants de la
communauté juif dont le grand Rabin de
France Rahim Corscia mais aussi de
plusieurs élus locaux l'initiative de
planter un arbre dans les ivelines pour
cette fête a été lancé par Samuel
Sandler l'ancien président de la
communauté juif de versaill père et
grand-père on le rappelle de trois
victimes des attentats de Toulouse et
Montauban qui est décédé le 12 janvier
dernier on écoute ces interviews au
micro de Grégory canalé on a pour
tradition de planter un arbre c'est ce
qu'on vient de faire on a planté un
olivier c'est le signe d'un renouveau
c'est le signe de la vie on a repris une
initiative qui avait été menée par
Monsieur Samuel Sandler qui avait planté
en 2002 quand il était président de la
communauté juive de Versailles un arbre
pour tout Bichevat à l'arboretom du
chînet et il nous vous avez soufflé en
novembre cette idée qu'il aurait aimé
revoir voir le jour et quand on lui a
annoncé que que nous allions replanter
mais cette fois-ci à Versailles il en
était plus que ravi voilà et c'est
encore plus beau aujourd'hui de se dire
qu'on a planté qu'on a une énorme pensée
pour lui une fête qui veut véhiculer un
message positif dans un contexte
particulier celui de la recrudescence
des actes antisémites en France ils ont
augmenté de 1000 % depuis attaque du
Hamas en Israël le 7 octobre dernier
écoutez Ellie Corchia président du
conshistoire Central Israélite de France
présent également aujourd'hui à
Versailles depuis le 7 octobre on s'est
rendu compte que nous avons eu une
augmentation de 1000 % en l'espace de 3
mois des actes antisémites en France
comparé à l'année dernière et sur toute
l'année ça donne du coup un chiffre de
plus de 300 % d'augmentation ce qui est
ahurissant puisque nous avons eu une
déferlante d'acte antisémite dès le 7
octobre dès qu'il y a eu en Israël ces
pogromes terroristes qui ont été menés
contre la population civile et bien nous
avons vu et puis le festival de musique
de de Nova qui a été décimé par les
terroristes et bien nous avons vu des
actes antisémites dans les jours qui ont
suivi nous avons vu des des actes
antisémites qui qui ont qui ont déferlé
en France donc c'est aussi pour ça que
dans cette cérémonie on voulait montrer
un message positif et la grande majorité
de ces actes antisémite vise les
personnes il s'agit de menaces d'insulte
mais aussi de violence physique on
poursuit c'est les informations du jour
Gabriel à Saint-Quentin en Yveline oui
l'agglomération tient ce soir sa
cérémonie de vœux au Vélodrome national
situé à Montini le bretonux et sur place
pour la rédaction de tv78 Grégory canalé
bonsoir Grégory la cérémonie débute à
19h bonsoir Gabri 19h et on procède
actuellement au dernier préparatif les
derniers échauffement puisquon on est
dans une sportive avant cette cérémonie
alors dans le discours on n' pas pu
encore consulter dans les allit dire le
président de l'agglomération de 50 ans
en evveline Jean-Michel Fourgous mais il
y a fort parier qu'il sera question
des qu'on attend avec ici du côté de
l'agglomération de 50 ans en ivine
puisque des épreuves vont se dérouler
sur le territoire ici même au Vélodrome
les épreuves de cyclisme sur piste il y
aura aussi les épreuves de BMX juste à
côté sur la du Vélodrome national de 50
ans en yeline les épreuves de VT sur la
colline d'lancour et bien sûr les
épreuves de golf au Golf National à
alors vous le savez aussi dans ces
cérémonies de vœux c'est la tradition il
y a des élus territoire nationau
présents dans ceux qui ont confirmé leur
présence on n pas la liste établie mais
on peut vous confirmer déjà ce soir du
Sénat Gérard Larcher qui sera donc au
côté et de 50 ans en Eveline pour cette
cérémonie de vœux qui débute ici à 19h
national merci beaucoup Grégory canalé
je crois que Lauren Merker sera aussi
également présent le maire de Montini le
Bretonneux il nous l'a dit à l'instant
on termine avec une information Gabriel
qui peut intéresser les jeunes en
orientation et qui doivent saisir en ce
moment leur vœux sur parcours sup
l'université de versaill Saint-Quentin
en Yveline ouvre ses portes au public ce
samedi 27 janvier oui tout à fait
Mathilde la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques accueillera ses
futurs étudiants potentiels entre 14h et
10 18h des rencontres avec les
professeurs et les anciens élèves seront
possibles sur ce campus de Guy encour en
parallèle des conférences seront animé
pour connaître les formations et les
différentes débouchées des métiers du
droit et de la science politique on
écoute Alain buit président de
l'université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yveline on accueille tous les étudiants
on accueille des étudiants avec desmion
très bien on accueille aussi des
étudiants avec des résultats un peu plus
modestes au bac et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que et c'est ce qui
fait la force de l'université c'est que
ça permet à tous ces étudiants de
révéler leurs talents et parfois on a
des extraordinaires euh expérience avec
des réussites
extraordinaires merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news